e
okay folks can you hear me no
okay so let's start with the big news of
the week right which is what's everybody
talking about is it a corporate finance
story now tell me the corporate finance
story what did deep I mean now there's
all the technology story what has deep
seek done that affects business revenues
profits go
ahead langage model which performs
compar
but at a
lower let's keep the national issue up
wake up in invid on Monday is your story
different right because until last
Friday the story was if you want to
create an AI product or service what do
you need to do invest in incredible
expensive data centers with very
expensive Invidia chips and have access
to immense amounts of data right that
was the prevailing wisdom and it pushed
up Nvidia it pushed up companies like
Constellation Energy you saying why
because data centers require immense
amounts of Power Talk of taking nuclear
power plants out of moth balls and
making them so these data centers
incredibly powerhand and you have a
whole ecosystem there are companies that
provide gas to these power centers and I
mean so there's a whole array what's the
essence of disruption you look at
something being done and everybody tells
you this is the way it has to be done
you say what if I could do it
differently and cheaper and that is at
the core of the deep seek story there's
a lot of stuff we don't know I mean
let's rule out the things we know are
just PR did it cost only 6.3 million to
develop deep sick of course not it
probably cost hundreds of millions
perhaps even a billion they probably use
some Invidia chips along the way to help
them out so it's not as if this was
created by three people in a Hut on the
top of the Himalayas with no access to
anything it was clear but even if it
cost a billion that's a lot less than
what micros meta alone spent what 65
billion on it but for some reason BCS
seem to think that it's not enough to be
impressive you got to be super
impressive so there's this part of the
story only 6 million it didn't cost but
it is I think the most impressive part
is that two years ago at the height of a
year ago the height of ai's hyper
everybody had bought into it right not
just investors but all of the tech
Titans said this is the way to do it
somebody sitting in a room in China said
Why That's How disruption always starts
why in my valuation class I'm going to
Value inia I'm going to go do a
valuation as of Friday because I've been
valuing in multiple times and I'm going
to Value it on Monday could the value be
different of course it's a corporate
finance story that's going to roll
through the next 15 weeks and Beyond and
for some of you pick a company in that
space and I'm going to talk about your
project it is going to be very much part
of what you will have to deal with when
you talk about thinking about the right
Corporate Finance actions for your
company I told you everything is
Corporate Finance
so today here's what I'd like to do I'd
like to start by kind of mopping up the
parts of the syllabus I didn't get to
especially that unpleasant part where
you actually have to get a
grade I could lie and say it's all about
the
learning I'd like to think that but
let's face it you want a grade you want
that grade to be a decent grade so I'll
lay the
foundations but if you remember last
class I described this class as a big
picture class but I also said it was a
applied class saying what does that mean
I want you to be able when you come out
of this class to be actually do things
with the corporate finance tool not just
talk about them not just hire McKenzie
to do them but do them
yourself so everything in this class I'm
going to apply in real
companies often in real time I've never
used to case study in 40 Years of
teaching and I think it's I don't want
to pass aspersions on other people using
case studies but I think it's a little
in my class when you've got 48,000 live
case studies out there to go talk about
a company and something that happened to
it in
1988 written by a Harvard Business
School Professor who knows the ending to
the story and acts like he or she
doesn't know it so they can look really
good in class because they could lead
the discussion to obviously Time Warner
should not b a really you need a case
study to show me
this the prom live case
studies is there're out of your
control and I think that's exciting that
you create a case study and you don't
know what the next thing is it's like
going to a
movie not one of those romcoms so you
know what the ending is right in ver
three minutes you know the first one a
movie where you don't know what's coming
so everything in this class I'm going to
apply on real companies because the
class has to have a structure I'm going
to set them back in 2013 but I'm going
to talk about these companies today
first company I'm going to use in this
class and I'm going to use it remember
the investment decision the financing
decision the Dividend
Decision is Disney why did I pick Disney
because everybody kind of knows what
Disney does right if I picked Alcoa
you'd be struggling for the next 15
years tell me again what Alcoa
does or Cisco what does Cisco do Disney
you kind of know right everybody's seen
Mickey Mouse and the theme parks and the
movies and the Avenger movies
Visa it's a large US entertainment
company and everything I do in this
class I'm going to apply on Disney so
I'm going to come up with a hurdle rate
come up with an investment for Disney
that I'm going to make up a Disney theme
park how would you assess it what's the
right financing mix for Disney how much
should Disney pay in
dividends and tie it all up with how
does this play out in Disney's
Val the second company I'm going to use
is a company called Val anybody know
what Val does
it's an iror Mining Company in
Brazil it's the largest iron or Mining
Company you saying why did you pick V to
be as different from Disney as I could
get right old economy new economy
Emerging Market develop market and to
put a you know icing on the cake here V
used to be a government-owned company
that's now a publicly traded company but
the Brazilian government maintains
what's called a golden share or the
equalent of veto power over big
decisions I want to talk about how
Corporate Finance decisions within V are
going to be affected by all of those
parameters the third company I'm going
to use is a company called TARTA
Motors what does tart motors do
obviously it makes
cars what kind of cars it used to be
Mass Market
automobiles it's been around India for a
long time until in 2009 mtiv did a
facelift a change which is it acquired
anybody know who it acquired Jaguar
landro a global luxury auto company but
the biggest story it's part of a family
group which is not uncommon in Asia and
Latin America many companies are parts
of family groups you're saying so
what in corporate finance we look at
investment financing and dividend
decisions as if the managers of the
company care just about the company but
if you're a company that's part of a
family group there's somebody above you
in fact with Tata the Tata group this is
actually very physical they're in one
building in Mumbai called Mumbai house
and each floor is top Executives of each
company and the very top floor used to
sit right and tied up the family
patriarch do you think anything happens
anything big happens in the lower floors
without it at least being passed by the
top floor if you do you're being
incredibly naive and here's what it
creates it creates decisions that
companies can make that sometimes are
not in the best interest of the company
why are they doing it but actually work
in the best interest of the group so I
want to talk about that conflict what
happens when companies have a part of a
family group and they have to think
about what's good for the group as
opposed theany the fourth company I'm
going to use is
B have any of you used
BYU come on if you're from China you
have to have used B but Buu is a search
engine he's saying why haven't I heard
of it for a good reason it's not a very
good search
engine but it dominates in China I still
remember my first trip to China I was
fly the long flight to Shanghai I'm
working on a blog
post I have Google Blog I'm very
oldfashioned so it's not been updated
since it's a very old fashion so I land
in Shanghai I open up my Google Blog and
it's not there so what the heck happened
I type in google.com and I don't comes
up I so the $2 billion company disappear
while I was in the air it turns out that
the Google search box is not technically
accessible you can get through it by
going through a VPN or double VPN which
I have no patience for Buu is a Chinese
search engine it's a technology company
it's a very successful Chinese
technology company because there a lot
of Chinese it's a big Market
why did I pick B because I wanted to
pick a Chinese company and I wanted to
pick a technology company this allowed
me to do both I was running out of time
for more companies so got both of the
fifth company I'm going to use is doche
why first because I like horror
stories and doche Bank reminds me of
that teenager in every Horror Story the
one I'm talking about you come to a
empty house it's dark
and the teenager opens the front door
and goes in he's saying what are you
doing and she keeps going and it's
usually a she it's very
sexist and they get to the entry to the
basement there's a basement door and you
can hear the sound of a chainsaw coming
from the basement come on you walk into
a dark house there's a chainsaw sound
coming from the basement what's any
rational person going to do you're going
to run out of that house as quickly as
you can but that's not what this
teenager does she opens the door she
walks down to the basement and the rest
as they say is blood gore in
history doche Bank does that every
single year right the basement is
another Christ says this time I've
learned my lesson I'll never go into the
basement again next year they repeat the
process so it's good to take a horror
story and say how did they get to be a
horror
story but along the way I also want to
talk about how is corporate different if
you're a regulated company
banks have the most regulations on what
they can or cannot do for inst we talked
about debt to equity and whe what you
with the bank that financing mix
question might be out of your hands
Regulators decide how much you can
use and the final company I'm going to
use is a not even a company it's a
bookstore in New York that I've changed
the name on called bookc privately owned
small
bookstore why did I pick it because I
want to take every corporate decision if
you're the owner of a small business a
plumbing
business an
electrician how do you navigate those
big
questions so as we go through this class
you're going to see me come back to
these companies and by the 15th week
you're going to be as familiar with
these companies as I am because they're
going to be the standards as we go
through as we go through this process
the question of course going to be
thinking about is what will the grade
look like I'll give away the game this
is a finance class we're all covered by
pretty much the same distribution it's
supposed to apply to all the other
departments but don't control them so
maybe you get 90% A's in the strategy
class that's not going to happen here
it's 30 35% A's about 50 55% B's and
there will be C's and D's for some
reason people think that those letters
of the alphabet have disappeared from
the grading system they're still there
but you really have to try to get
them how am I going to decide well I
have subjectively if
you get it and I'll decide you've got it
it's a or a minus you almost get it know
it's a b if you you're trying to get it
it's not catching if you don't even know
what it is and then clearly the D's and
the fs are what are we talking about for
15 weeks hopefully you will not end up
in that last slice I don't like to put
people there because then I've got to
deal with the number of people who end
up in that space so I'm going to try as
hard as I can to keep you on the right
side of this divide but here's what your
grade is going to be based on there will
be a case and I have to change the due
date on this because for some reason our
spring break is a week later than it was
and that happens to be spring break week
I'm not a sadistic enough to say your
project is Du in the middle of spring
break so I will change the date probably
to the next week what is the case going
to be I don't know I I haven't written
it
yet I concoct a case maybe deep seek
will be a good thing to build the case
around but leave that to me so somewhere
in about two or three weeks you will get
a case you'll work on it as a group
you're saying what group start thinking
about forming a group of people I won't
put you in a group right so you
basically you're saying what if I can't
find a group
until last year I used to create an
orphan
list where you could put your name on
and you could get adopted but then
somebody last year told me that this was
very inconsiderate and that was hurting
their
feelings so I called it I will call it
something else let's call it Corporate
Finance
limbo isn't that the place in in the
Catholic really where you end up in this
middle space you're not sure where you
are well right is it limbo limbo might
be the dance but you know whatever it is
we'll call it something so you can go
put your names in there and you will get
either adopted or better still you can
get other people just like you and
create a list of people in
limbo but you have to find a group the
case will be and you write a case report
obvious State the OB be one report for
the whole group and there'll be one
grade for the whole group that's
somewhere in the middle of the semeer
the other project is a project where
you're going to pick a company so I want
you to start thinking about a company
and you're going to work on that company
through the class as a group each of you
in the group has to pick a company I
would like that company to have a common
theme partly to so that you don't have
to start so let's take a theme you could
take semiconductors what's going to be
in that group you could have Invidia and
that group you could all you know take
Intel the two ends of the life cycle
you're right one is of course this
company that could do no har no nothing
wrong until last Friday and the other
company that seems to be able to do
nothing right right now it's good to
have Divergence that's what you're
looking for you might throw companies
that feed into the semiconductor space
they don't all have to be but what
you're looking for are companies that
are
different so you're doing
retail you might pick Amazon but pick
marcard Libra which is a latinum
American online retail company pick
Walmart a traditional physical retail
company a Target if you want to or a
small retailer if you want to Niche
retailer but you're looking for
something in common but each of you will
work on your company saying what's the
group structure going to do I wanted to
talk about what you find about your
company that's different from what other
people find then ask
why so if you find that your company
takes on a lot of debt and another
company supposedly space same space
you're a hospit your your group is
hospitality and for of you picked hotels
and the fifth picked Trav velocity and
the
sixth picked
Airbnb I can almost guarantee you before
you start that airbnb's Corporate
Finance decisions are going to be very
different than Marriott's decisions and
the class is not just about chronicling
numbers in fact I have a spreadsheet
right now they'll do all the numbers for
you you don't need an AI I could
actually make it an AI this is about you
reading the numbers and creating
narrative so if you haven't thought
about it already start thinking about a
group obviously got to get the group on
I Define theme very broadly I mean last
last semester people one group picked
Vice they did gambling
tobacco cannabis they picked a can
Canadian cannabis dog they had a lot of
fun a casino in there I mean basically
you can
you can Define your theme and pick a
theme that you're interested in don't
ask what will be easy ask yourself what
would be interesting hey because I
guarantee no matter what company you
pick the one there are two thing two
types of companies I'd like you to avoid
one
is money losing companies Young Money
losing companies and I'll tell you why
Corporate Finance becomes far too simple
and here's what if you're a young money
losing company how much money can you
borrow don't think too
long if you're in a hold stop digging
right you can't how much can you pay out
in
dividends so you're going to be after
you get through the investment section
you're saying what do I do next my
optimal debt ratio is zero and I can't
pay dividends and you're going to come
and complain to me and say I told you
not to pick a money losing
company so pick a money-making company
and avoid Banks unless you really want
to spend your life following Banks why
because banks are regulated you have to
understand you know what the difference
is between tier one capital and tier 2
capital and if you don't want to spend
your life learning that minutia because
it's not interesting to you it's not the
place you want to be so if you're a
group and you really want to do banks or
insurance companies because you're all
kind of strange Financial Service
Company people come and talk to me i' be
willing to help but in
stay away from
it there will be three quizzes for this
class the dates are
specified there will be unfortunately
given the size of this class I have zero
flexibility in terms of moving the quiz
I can't give it earlier I can't give it
later why because the quiz will leak
right I have to write a fresh quiz and I
am lazy and it creates all kinds of
logistical challenges but I do
understand that life gets in the way
that you might not be able to make a qu
why because you have an interview I
understand you came for an NBA to get a
job and I understand that has to take
and if you do miss a
quiz you don't lose the 10% it gets
moved towards left in the class so if
you miss the first quiz which is a 10%
quiz your second and third quiz will be
worth 12% a piece your final will be
worth
36% if you miss the second
quiz then your third quiz will get
bumped up to 15 the so basically it'll
always go forward why because otherwise
you'll get strategic quiz missing right
you know what I mean by that you do
really well in the first two quizzes you
miss the third quiz because it actually
weights your first two quizzes more I've
been teaching 40 years no game I don't
want you to game the system so basically
but you will not the one advantage of
taking all three quizzes now got to
throw a little sweetener in there
otherwise saying why don't I just miss
one of the three is in addition to
learning all the material as it happens
because that's what you have to do for
the quizzes I will take your worst quiz
and replace the score in your worst quiz
with the scores on your on your other
two quizzes so let's take an extreme
example you get a 10 on quiz one you get
a zero on quiz do why bad things happen
to you that then third quiz you back to
10 I will take the zero and replace with
the 10 right actually it'll be the
average across the two quizzes and the
final exam but you get the picture right
basically I will take your worst quiz
and and give you the quiz on the average
grade on the rest of your
exams there is a final exam date I as I
said I'll put it up uh you know it's I
think the week after but we'll have to
you know I we'll talk about because if
you have to leave early you might have
to have is so we we'll talk about if you
have issues in timing we'll deal with
that as well you can go through this
page when you get a chance but it gives
you good reasons for missing a quiz like
what I'll give you a bad reason I don't
feel ready so here's my suggestion if
you're really not ready and that's your
reason at least do me the service of
coming up with a reason that sounds good
right you know I'll let you I'm not
going to ask you for a doctor's note I'm
going to trust you we're adults here but
adults lie to each other all the time so
I don't even know why we say we're
adults here as if that leads to
truthfulness now so if you want to miss
a quiz I won't stop you
but remember if you do miss a quiz you
lose that best of the three the worst of
the three quiz option and you also miss
learning for that quiz which you will
need because the final exam is always a
comprehensive
f it is open book open
notes and open devices and the reason
for that is how many of you have your
lecture notes or an iPad or a computer
pretty much everybody right who prints
off stuff so given that it's open book
open Notes if I don't let you open your
devices that that kind of defeats the
open Notes but you cannot use Excel on
your laptop partly because you don't
need the problems are written such a way
that you can do the numbers by hand and
partly because you have 200 200 people
trying to work with excel in a room bad
things happen right computers break down
there's noises of beeping and so
basically you can use devices you can do
notes you can do you can do whatever you
want you can summarize It Whatever work
for your learning you can bring it in
this is not about checking whether you
remember an equation it's about checking
whether you remember there was an
equation and where to find it in your
notes right because which requires that
you actually go through the notes before
and as I said every exam I've ever given
in this class I think my very first exam
is 1986 is
online and solutions obviously are
online as well that's where the review
sessions will cover the T will go
through those problems
on the group work as I said pick your
own group and police it
yourself again this is where the your
adults part of it comes in but I said
the same thing to Manda graduates who
are 21 years
old figure out the what I mean by police
it is there's always this one person in
the group you know the one I'm talking
about who never seems to keep
up 14th week they still haven't picked a
company and remember this is a group
project your great drives on saying what
do I do what's the
Godfather there's some good suggestions
on how to get people to do things
right get your message across don't make
me the messenger right I mean it's I I
would be fired if I chopped off
somebody's um Pet's head and put it on
the that's what I saw in The Godfather
but figure out a way to keep them in
line okay
that's about it for the class as as far
class
participation there are no rules other
than don't start yelling at each other
across the room anything is fair gate so
if you want the problem with the class
this big is you feel intimidated to ask
questions when you start hopefully
that'll fade you'll be more willing to
jump in so please do jump in you know
contest something I say if you think
it's you know that you have a different
View I'm not going to be in the least
bit insulted because you did that it'll
actually make it more fun the more you
talk the less I have to talk which means
it makes my job
easier any yeah there's somebody already
jumping in yeah so the the casch 26
that's spring bre were you here so
remember I said yesterday about
physically being here but mentally you
might be gone have you been here right
from the beginning of the class
ask your neighbor what I just talk said
about when the case is
Du okay so no we we'll let that pass
right so in a sense it can happen it's a
perfect example for why everything is
recorded and online is because these
moments will happen so don't take it
personally it does happen it's okay so
no so let's turn to the first lecture
note packet because now we're going to
start the process so
this packet is about 300 and something
pages so we're going to roll this is
going to take you through the 15th
session so if you got this packet this
15th session make sure you download the
second packet because it'll take you
through the rest of the class today I
want to focus on something we don't talk
about
enough in any of our classes which is
it's a business school right all these
classes and here's a core question what
is the end game when you run a business
if you asked Milton fredman that
question what would he have told
you if you get a chance go and read
Milton fredman's
1971 piece it's an opinion piece in the
New York Times what would Milton
Freedman say your endgame is is a
business well he basically said you
create a product or service that people
need that they will pay you for you make
money on it and it's not just profits
this year but profits in the long term
you run businesses to make money that's
so mercenary I know but that's the end
game and of course you get push back on
that which is businesses have bigger
objectives more purposes and in fact
much of the push back has been around
for as long as
time you know how Adam Smith
described economics right anybody know
what what his description of Economics
was Adam Smith of course
six father of free
market a lot of stuff for like the
Invisible Hand the Invisible Hand is a
good way it's a gospel of
Mammon is how he described it if you
have no idea what Mammon is go look it
up and Google it's not a good
description basically that you do things
that could be essentially the between
good and evil that you might walk very
close to it but the essence of a
business is your business but push back
has been around as long as business been
around and in the last 20 years this
push back has kind of acquired this
special power behind it partly because
Harvard Business School threw its lot in
there and they're always the first
movers here and Harvard Business School
exists for one reason and one reason
alone to make consulting firms a lot of
money because they create an acronym
consulting firms run with it
and of course there are three forms this
push back has taken the first is
sustainability I'm sure you I'm sure
some of you have classes with the word
sustainability in it some of you might
have had titles at the works you had
sustainability it's a big word out
there but the idea is you want to put
sustainability presumably of the planet
but I'm going to come back and push back
of sustainable what because
sustainability people just say
sustainability
it predates business right Planet
sustainability is something that
environmentalists have fought for Green
Peace for instance going back a century
but this is Corporate sustainability and
we got to ask what are we
sustaining the second is this notion of
stakeholder
wealth who's a stakeholder pretty much
everybody right your customers are
stakeholders your employees are
stakeholders the bankers are
stakeholders Society is
stakeholder that maybe this shareholder
thing is too narrow that we need to
think about all
stakeholders and the third of
course is that acronym
ESG and I'll give you my PRI when I
asked what I think about ESG I said it
was born in
santimon nurtured with
hypocrisy and sold with sophistry
there's nothing good I can say about
this Acron but we'll come back and talk
about why because it sounds good right
you're saying what is wrong with caring
about the environment caring about
society and caring about governance my
response is if you truly care about
these things the last thing you should
be doing is putting your trust in
ESG so let's start with this notion of
stakeholders who are the stakeholders in
the company obviously shareholders are
stakeholders why because they Supply the
equ Capital lenders are stakeholders
because they lend money to a firm
employees are stakeholders because they
get the wages from the company customers
are stakeholders because they have
interactions with the company products
and services Society is a stakeholder in
the form of a government because the
government collects taxes from the
company and might pass rules and
regulations and laws the company has to
operate under even your competition is a
stakeholder the only problem is they're
a stakeholder with a very different
interest and you they want you to go
down but everybody has a stake in the
company and in corporate finance we
Elevate one of these stakeholders to the
top of the pyramid and who do we put at
the top of the pyramid and that is
where the disagreement starts why would
you this like it looks like we're
playing favorites right so does somebody
want to tell me why shareholders get
this special place where they get to
pick the management they get to run the
firm what is is it about their
relationship with the company that makes
us put it put it put them on top of the
fa you think A lender lending to a risky
compan is not carrying if it to a risk
employees might lose their job I mean
you could argue that the employee risk
is actually much more tangible than a
investor who has 50 other companies in
their portfolio risk alone can't explain
it
yep they just own The Firm so owners get
to do whatever they want that sounds
like you know if you have the power you
should be able to carry it through
that's a very brutal reason for
it okay let's get closer I think we're
getting closer to the truth lenders lend
money to the firm right but when you
lend money whether you're a banker a
bond holder what do you do you get a
contract that protects you y incentives
directly align I think that's what it's
going to come out of the contractual
relationship I mean the alignment issue
comes about because we put is on top
it's almost an output the question is
why do we create that input lenders lend
money to a firm they have a contract and
in the contract what do they do they set
the interest rate based on how much risk
they see in you they write covenants on
what you cannot cannot cannot do
sometimes they screw
up but they have a contract
employees have a contract now we can
debate whether those contracts have
become too weak because of the you know
because of weak ing of labor unions but
there's a contract
right there's a wage you might say I
don't like the wage quit and go work for
somebody else your benefits basically
you get a contract do customers have a
contract hey you buy a product or
service and it doesn't do what you
thought I mean you might have a tough
time returning it wasn't from Amazon but
you can return it you can demand your
money back and if they don't do it you
can if you if you're willing to spend
the time and the resources you can there
is a contract every customer purchase is
an implicit
contract does the government have a
contract with a
company right the T you can think about
this whole process of the contract right
you pay taxes in return the government
provides protection on your patent so
basically there again we can argue
whether those contracts have been
weakened and exploited but there's a
contract and even competition has his
own contract right especially in the US
with antitrust laws you can go the the
only group that does not have a
contractual relationship is shareholders
what do they get they get whatever's
left over let's be real let's suppose
you invest and I tell you you get
whatever's left over and I say go in now
I'm going to let the other people run
this business how much are you going to
get left
over
nothing you know why universities never
run a surplus they always run at a
deficit because there is no they
basically take the pie and say who's
getting what slice of the pie and then
they run out of the pie and they go
borrow more
pies the reason we put shareholds up
it's not because we like shareholders
that they're preferred it's because they
have a
residual claim and if you don't lend the
Run let them run the company in the long
term nobody will take that residual
claim
so in practice we it is true we put
shareholders in toob and then we go
through this exercise where we start to
narrow how we think about that
objective traditional corporate
financing objective is to maximize the
value of the entire
business and then we ask managers go
ahead and do it but here's the problem
managers and somebody brought this up
are accountable to one remember the
capital for a business comes from both
lenders and shareholders managers and
most companies tend to be accountable to
which of those two
groups unless you're into distress the
lenders really don't run the man manager
so in practice instead of maximizing
firm value sh managers focus on
maximizing shareholder weth the portion
of the capital that comes from so we've
already narrowed the
objective the problem with shareholders
wealth is who's going to estimate you
could call in McKenzie every year to do
it first you got to pay that Hefty fee
second it's objective so if you're a
publicly traded firm that objective gets
maximum gets uh narrowed even further in
a publicly traded firm there is an
observable number for the shareholder
weth right which
is the market
price so in practice when people talk
about Corporate Finance they say the
objective in corporate finance is to
maximize stock prices right and it's
really not but you get there because
pragmatically if you run a publicly
traded company as a manager you end up
focusing on maximizing stock prices I'll
make a confession that's
terrifying because we know that that's
built on the presumption that the
markets get this at least reasonably
right right so I'm going to start with
with this maximizing stock price which
is a narrower version of maximizing the
value of the firm talk about why we
picked it as an objective in corporate
finance what can go wrong and horrible
things can happen at companies when you
when you try to maximize stock
prices and then talk about what do we do
instead so there I'll bring in every
possible alternative including
sustainability ESG and we'll pass them
through the test of hey will this work
better than maximizing stock prices so
let's start
with what I think is common sense when
you run an organization you have to you
can have only one
objective you can't have five objectives
you can have one objective in multiple
constraints you say why can't I do all
of these things because you will have to
make choices say I want to maximize
Revenue growth and margins and value hey
you know what that I I would like to do
all of those things as well but if you
run a business sometimes you have to
decide which one you want to put on top
so you have to decide tell me what your
central objective is and I'll let you
have
constraints now of course no you can
disagree with the central objective I
pick but don't tell me you want five
objectives that's why I don't like
company mission statements that have
seven different things they claim to do
come on guys make up your mind what are
you really trying to do what are your
constraints objective and constraints
and if the company is traded focusing in
stock prices comes with a bonus right
what's a bonus it's updated
constantly so on Monday morning this
week what happened in video St stock
price it drops 16% let's make it real
that's
580 billion dollar Invidia lost more in
market cap on Monday at opening than the
entire African Equity markets put
together the dollar values are
staggering why because Market said the
game has changed you know how long it's
going to take accountant to come to that
recognition probably 2 and a half years
it'll eventually percolate its way
through markets you get instantaneous
results and if if investors are rational
and that's a big if then that adjustment
reflects what the loss or gain and value
is so that's a nice thing about stock
prices you don't have to wait around to
say did I do the right thing you get
instantaneous
feedback and people don't like this
objective okay so when you look at this
objective they always go
back to the worst case scenario and this
is to me the strawman version of
corporate finance that if you let
Corporate Finance play out we're going
to have what I
call the original corporatism which is
19th century you know Rockefellers and
carnegies essentially their endgame was
they would maximize stock prices and the
rest of the world be
that my son's fiance's sister's husband
is a
Rockefeller he's a real Rockefeller not
the John D Rockefeller he'd be 150 years
old he's a very nice guy but I was
terrified when I first met him because I
had visions of John D Rockefeller coming
through and I'm sure that John de
Rockefeller was not a particularly fun
person to hang out with I know Andrew
Carnegie did amazing things every
library in the east coast came out of a
Carnegie but Andrew Cari was not
ruthless so the straw man is if you
maximize stock prices we're all going to
be back at the end of the 18th century
and you're going to
have and there are people who play that
out right look at the tech Giants
they're going to
be we'll come back and talk about why
this is not a repeat at the end of the
18th century but that's your and there
what do what do the people running the
company do they really exploit every
single other state
C starting with lenders right they have
the power to actually get rates at rates
below what they should be
paying employees employes in the rate
1800s at zero protection you could work
16 hours in a
mind probably didn't have any health
benefits died there was no nothing that
you
did customers remember I talked about
contesting the company if you don't like
what you get forget about that when
you're dealing with us steel and it's
your only company around making steel
you take it or leave
it you saying what about governments
these were so big that they did
governments did what they wanted them to
do rather than the other way around they
wrote the
regulations what about the competition
what
competition the original idea of
creating a trust was to eliminate
competition so if this is the word we're
going to end up in I don't want it
either so as I listen to critiques of
people of companies focus on stock
prices I hear three broad themes come
through and if you're not if you're in
the outside I would fault you for
believing that these themes are what dry
the first is that if you maximize stock
prices you can't take care of your
employees that the companies that
maximize stock prices care about their
Financial Health must be doing it at the
expense of employees and let's face it
every day you wake up at least one new
story where this things to play out
right and how does it play out Verizon
lays off 20,000
employees and you keep reading the story
the stock price went up 3% and your mind
you're making connection laying off
employees must mean stock prices go up
so if you care about maximizing profits
and value and stock prices it must come
at the expense of employees
of course that's going to be true in
individual cases but let's talk about in
general is that true would you rather
have worked at Tesla over the last
decade or GM at the last
decade this is a no-brainer right would
you rather work at Amazon or Walmart
much as we like to complain about
Amazon Amazon
workers are happier at Amazon than
Walmart he's how do you know I interview
all of them I went to glass door if you
to glass door you can actually go see
what what companies G
at and I and once I was there it was
fascinating I going to say what the
happiest places in America to work with
are these the places that don't care
about profits well I pulled up the list
and I'm going to show it to you and you
can make your own judgments
on this is not in your notes because I
just pulled it up this morning
these are the happiest places to work at
at least according to glas ban and
Company why because you're probably
being paid a ton of money have an
expense account and you have crew Car
Wash I don't know I want to drive
through crew I mean I say in andout
Burger I do go to in andout Burger in
California people are very happy maybe
they get to eat unlimited Burgers and
Fries
there's of course Invidia not Intel
notice the Church of Jesus day you know
that tells you also that employees are
not made happy just by paying the mahay
that there's a cultural issue which can
keep something that investment Banks
started forgetting in the 1980s right
because when I started in the 1980s when
you walked into Investment Bank you
actually could tell where you were
without looking at the name at the top
because Solomon is full of these scuffy
trade ERS none of them even if they wear
a tie the tie was never nodded all the
way it's pulled down your shirt was
pulled off and you walked into Morgan
Stanley the tie is all tied up
everybody's wearing the same suit it's
almost like they went to the same store
probably Barney and they bought the
store there was a cultural connection
the advantage of that is people then
self- select to be there even if they
don't get even if they get paid less
because they like the culture and
somewhere in the 1980s investment Banks
they could they should compete on one
dimension and you know exactly what the
dimension is because you had interaction
with them either in the interviews which
is we'll pay you
more and I know I caution them I said if
you play this game you know where it's
going to end up right if that's the
dimension then people are going to come
to you because you pay the most but then
if D sha pays even more they're going to
leave you and go to D shop because you
created the game there's zero loyalty
left in this system precisely because
you took it out so I'm glad you got the
Mormon Church up there right that's the
Church of Latter Day Saints because it
kind of brings home that fact that
employee
satisfaction no you're saying doesn't
that show you should maximize no it
basically says that if you look at
employee satisfaction it has know very
little to do with you saying the right
things to the rest of the world but
treating people right and doing well as
an institution and the Church is
financially the healthiest church out
there the Catholic church is wealth is
is also wealthy but it's all in the VCT
and basement and stuff so it doesn't
have the cash infl it's got a cash flow
problem right now so don't but don't
lose any you know sleep over it they'll
fix it somehow you know the worst places
to work
with
oh top is DHL Express second is United
and I can attest to this because I have
frequent interactions with United it's
my Airline of
choice partly because it's the only
airline that flies enough flights to San
Diego that I can be on it but as you go
down this list there aren't too many
healthy companies on this list right is
there even a Radio Shack around I don't
know what they must have found the last
employee at Radio Shack who works at
this Legacy stores what do you think
about and even that guy doesn't like
radio
Shin I'll wagor that if you walk into a
department store anywhere in the you're
not going to be surrounded by happy
people that these are people clearly
there because they get a paycheck and
they're not
particularly satisfied so let's put this
mythology to the side that if you now
ultimately if you really want to take
care of your employees you got to start
by doing financially well right
second you're told that if you want to
maximize stock price it must mean you
don't care about your
customers I should remember about 30
years ago I did a session for The Gap it
was part of a top Management Group this
was in the Gap was actually a successful
retail soore they kept opening new they
just opened Banana Republic and Old Navy
so they had a lot of money and the way
you could tell is they had this
management meeting at in
Sundance and even in Sundance is this
Robert Redford Ran So it's a in a hotel
room probably cost $1,000 a
night so they bring in people from
different disciplines to talk to the top
management I had the singular Misfortune
of following the
marketing Guru to the podium cuz just
before he left the objective of the Gap
should be to maximize customer
satisfaction then he left I wish he'd
stayed cuz I got up to the podum said
this is the stupidest objective I've
ever
heard how many of you have actually
shopped at the
Gap see how few hands go up already you
can see why they're in trouble think
about your collective experience
shopping though and think about what you
know what makes you satisfied you walk
in it's nice if the store is well lit
and you know it's it's got so you walk
in through and then you find the KHAK
Keys you want is that all Gap cells I'm
pretty much it right right in the siid
you want in the color you want they
actually make khakis and colors other
than khakis so don't ask me
why you're feeling pretty satisfied
right and then you get ready to leave
and there's a scrimp on your
satisfaction which
is you got to stop at the damn cash
register to pay for your khaki so if you
took the marketing
gurus objective to Heart what should you
do take the cash registers out
your sat your customers will be
incredibly satisfied for a couple of
weeks and then you go bankrupt you think
that is so absurd customer satisfaction
matters but why does it matter because
you want them to come back and I'm inan
I shop at Costco you know the great
thing about Costco is you can buy stuff
and return it there are people who bring
in two-year-old
refrigerators and I didn't like this
refrigerator
Costco will take it back but they'll
also take your membership away so that's
the cost
right Costco keeps its customer
satisfied and I like them for it but
they do it because they want you to get
a Costco membership and
keep so I agree you want customers to be
satisfied but let's be very clear you
want customers to be satisfied because
you want them to come back to you to
sell them stuff you could make customer
Satisfied by selling stuff below cost
but how long will you survive as a
business by
doing and there's a final Canard about
stock price maximization which is if you
maximize stock prices you must be some
kind of moral trog
Lite that's how I describ myself when I
wrote first about ESG I said you're
going to think I'm a moral
trite but I'm okay with
that I'll give you how the rest of the
World Views corporate finance and you're
going to see this happen when you show
up at Thanksgiving this year
at whatever family Thanksgiving you're
in you're going to tell them that you're
in an MBA program and people are already
going to start to bring you down the
morality scale then you say I'm going to
go work for a hedge fund and now you're
really scraping the bottle and say I
work in corporate finance and you're
done because here's the vision of
corporate finance that the rest of the
world
has I'm going to give you an assignment
for this weekend I want you to watch
this movie called other people money
it's a very old movie it's a 1980s movie
and I'll tell you the
storyline and going I tell you the story
it's the most boring movie it's actually
a fun movie it's about
a for lack of a better word at that time
they didn't call them P guys a PE guy
private Equity
guy who does a hostile
acquisition of a cable company in New
England you know phone cables
so the movie plays out where the acquir
buys the company and basically it's a
contest between the CEO of the company
and this hostile
acquir so think of the acquirer saying
he he wants maximize value I want to
increase the stock price you know who
played the aquire anybody know D Danny
Deo so I want you to visualize Danny
dito it's always sun in Philadelphia
remains one of my favorite shows but
there's Danny Deo that's corporate
finance you know who played the CEO of
the phone company Gregory PE Gregory
peek you guys have never seen Gregory
peek distinguish gray
hair there's your corporate finance and
anti-corporate finance basically do you
want to be Danny deito do you want to be
Gregory peek right but in this movie the
good part of it is it actually plays up
the climactic moment for the movie is an
annual
meeting and Danny DeVito gets up and
everybody in the meeting is the
employees this how dare you kill a
company it's been around a 100 years
it's amazing company and he says look I
am going to kill your company but it's
not me that's causing
it it's a fact that you make cables that
fiber optics is doing it to you I am the
Messenger
here but you know want I know private
Equity is AC Qui old and private Equity
walks very close to that line there are
things that private Equity does
especially in healthcare that I think
are almost
unconscionable but for the most part if
you look at what private Equity does it
essentially comes into businesses where
what somebody is doing doesn't make
sense anymore and they say you know what
maybe you should stop doing
it it's easy to blame the
messenger so if
you're equating maximizing talk price
with being a bad person go ahead but I
think in a sense there are a lot of bad
people who destroy their companies and
lower stock prices as well now goodness
and Badness is a distribution you're
going to find pretty much all kinds of
companies so these are the the facile
ways you kind of push so I'm going to
start with what I call the utopian World
from which Corporate Finance is
born when did Utopia exist what is
Utopia
never existed so already I'm giving you
a precursor that what I'm going to
describe in this world is going to be
completely unrealistic but hang in there
in the utopian World which Corporate
Finance Bor here are the here's the way
the world works first stockholders in
this world in publicly traded companies
have complete power over managers I want
you to think of a company you own shares
in and think of how much power you have
and already you can see Utopia moving
further and further away from you you
own those matter shares complete power
over matter are you kidding me but let's
stay in this utopian world how do they
exercise that power through the annual
meeting and through the board of
directors remember in theory the board
of directors works for the shareholders
its job is to oversee management to make
sure they're doing their fiduciary
duty and what do managers do they're so
terrified of shareholders they go out
and do the right thing know increase
value for shareholders in this word
lenders lend money to a firm and they
write no prot
ctions and for whatever reason the
company doesn't take advantage of all of
those loopholes why because it come back
to the borrow money it's a reputation
effect and I can tell you stories about
how you can get away with it but in this
world that always happens you lend money
you don't protect yourself you never get
ripped off this world you when as a
company something happens to you you go
out to financial markets and you tell
them what happened
honestly and on time
now we're really approaching the far
edges of Utopia right so what Universe
in the world that I just
described here's what would happen and
I'll take a personal example I've been
an Apple user since 1981 and I'd wait a
long time for an Apple laptop to arrive
didn't come till the early '90s it's
called the power book it was just
Loosely a laptop it weighed like 15
pounds and got really hot on your lap
you get burns on your your
but and and we were happy as Apple users
it did have one small issue it's
sometimes caught
fire this is not exactly a feature you
go looking for on a laptop right
spontaneous combustion not there not
there not there it'll make your next
presentation incredibly
memorable but your next plane trip could
be a disaster turned out the batteries
that Apple was using were overheating
and just blowing up now in the world
that I describe what would Apple do to
run out of markets right away and say
guys our laptops are
hot just leave it at that technically
you're not
lying and that's something to remember
about companies you don't actually have
to lie you just have I told you have
four kids you know I they don't actually
lie to me but they sometimes hold back
the truth we all do
it but the world that that never happen
we all tell the truth to each other
we're like blurred out everything
and in return what do markets do they're
cool and rational about what you just
told them I'll describe a trading grou
in this world it'll be full of
intellectual
people have any of you been in a trading
room full of intellectual people right
who have long conversations about the
long
term but
really but in this world that's what
happens and finally in this
world there are no social costs
what's a social cost anybody want to
tell me that because or in economics we
call these externalities right what is
it nobody wants try go
ahead on the rest of society right but
we have to finish the costs that are
created for society that you can't
generally Trace back to the companies
right because you can trace it back
there are ways to make the company pay
but generally social costs are cost that
are you know and already you're saying
but only bad companies create social
costs everybody does that hot dog stand
out sir I briefly considered using that
as my six business it's greater social
cost for
me it's been around 38 years I know the
guy really well but I often walk down
that that that uh that sidewalk and he's
cost me like 15 steps every day for the
last you're saying this is so
petty hey think of the thousands of
people who walk down multiply by 15
Steps is right in the middle of the
sidewalk sometimes you slip on ice
because you can't get that's a social CA
companies when they run businesses
create ca for
society and we'll talk about why that's
an issue but in the utopian world well
there are no social
costs why am I doing this because in
economics when you have a problem you
can't deal with what do you do you
assume it away you put yourself on an
island let's live it because what we're
trying to do is make the world safe for
maximizing stock price in what sense I
want you to maximize stock prices the
right way what's the right way you got
to go out and pick good Investments make
good
products that so much work
because you can go increase stock prices
by stealing from your bond holders by
ripping off your
customers by not paying taxes that you
should be paying in this world none of
that stuff happens but let's start with
that world because in a sense it's going
to give us that that standard that we
can compare so in the utopian world what
do companies do they maximize stock
price because markets are efficient when
you maximize stock price what do you do
you maximize stock holder wealth so we
got rid of that
problem lenders are not ripped off so
basically when I maximize stockholder
whether it's not coming from ripping off
my
lenders this world is a utopian World
employees are paid a reasonable wage
because you want them to work you don't
exploit
them same thing with customers you
basically provide them the product you
would you get a reasonable price you pay
a fair share of taxes you follow the
rules and the
regulations and it's like a Disney movie
everybody lives happily ever
after I don't know about you but I don't
live in this
world every one of those assumptions I
listed is patently unrealistic so let's
go to the real world and all hell is
going to break loose let's start with
the first linkage what did I say
stockholders have complete power over
managers well not
really and as you go outside the US it
gets worse Japanese companies Indian
family group companies and we talk about
the two mechanisms annual meetings and
Boards of directors and why they don't
work and if shareholders have little
power over managers what do they do they
put their interest often ahead of
shareholder interest it's human nature
it's not because they're bad people so
why do you have an apartment on Fifth
Avenue if you're the CEO of a company
you can give me all kinds of you know
this is for convenience but you don't
need a penthouse apartment and you could
get a hotel room in in Midtown manatt
good room
too managerial interests get ahead we'll
take look at examples of that lenders
lend money to a firm and you don't
protect it so what's going to happen
you're going to get ripped off it's not
a question of whether it's a question of
when do companies sometimes lie to
financial markets
absolutely but all too often it's not
that they lie but that they TR to delay
bad news manage the flow and in turn
markets are not Angelic either right
that cool rational Market is not exactly
the trading room what do you think
happened on Monday morning you think
people over the weekend work through the
expected Revenue growth for Invidia over
the next 20 years and what deep seek
could do to their margins think so they
came in and they're
sold and finally do companies create
social costs
absolutely do they sometimes create
social business that too
it's a messy word and I'd like to take
each of these linkages and take a deeper
look let's start with the first linkage
in theory shareholders have complete
power over managers how do they get
there by through the annual meeting of
the board of directs let's start with in
practice why those two mechanisms don't
work let's start with the annual meeting
how many of you are shareholders in
publicly traded
companies okay so quite a few the rest
of you had to sell your shares to pay
the tuition I would guess I understand
right how many of you have been to an
annual
meeting one couple people that's good
I've never I own shares in 40 companies
I've never been to an annual meeting and
I don't intend to start I'll give you an
example I own shairs in
Coca-Cola I've never been to an annual
meeting because think through the proc
what this involves I first have to fly
to Atlanta it's an extraordinarily
overpriced flight from New York New York
and even more so from San Diego let's
say it's $600 I have to stay in that
peach whatever section of Atlanta this
is really depressing part of Atlanta
where everybody seems to leave at 7 p.m.
that'll cost me another
$600 add up the meals and the other
stuff $1,500 round trip there goes my
profit for the year right for most of us
it makes no sense to go to an annual
meeting but in theory I can be there
without actually being there I'm not
being mist ious but as shareholders in a
company what do you usually get the
right to
do you get a proxy the old days it
actually used to be a physical document
you got in the mail I remember getting
that
document and you know what I did with
that document if I was feeling
environmentally conscious it went into
recycling if not it went into trash I
had zero interest in filling out that
proxy because most of the time I was
asked to vote for people I never heard
of or in Pro or things that would come
up which I didn't really care about you
know that I'm not alone that 60% of
proxies never get returned but those are
thousand shares in Coca-Cola right so
when I threw it in the trash or
recycling what happened to the Thousand
votes where does it go where do they
go in much of the world when proxies
don't get voted those votes go to income
incumbent
managers see what this process does
right it's like having an election where
the incumbent gets the votes of anybody
who doesn't show up to vote no us
incumbent would ever get defeated right
because I think what 49% of people show
up to vote you start with 51% you don't
even have to vote for yourself you've
already won it's a process tilted
towards incumbents which is one reason
when you look at votes at annual
meetings it's very very difficult not
impossible talk about what might tip it
over the edge to get to 25 when you see
a 30% no vote against management at an
annual meeting that must mean that
pretty much everybody voted voted
against management but they started with
70% I just remember when JP Morgan had
this issue with Jamie
Diamond what you know there was a pro
proposal to put him back as the chair of
the board again because he' done the
right corporate governance thing and
stop being chair of the board but he
wanted to be chair of the board why
because he's a bit of a
megalomaniac so opposition you know sh
said that's not right the corporate
governance thing you did the right thing
you start so it comes up for a vote and
there a
36% no vote and 64 so the way the Wall
Street Journal report The Wall Street
Journal article on it reported was Jamie
Diamond wins because 64% of the people
voted for him the shareholders voted for
him not
really it's very difficult to get a no
vot at a at an annual meeting right so
most of so it's not just small store but
but he's saying what about the big
institutional
investors what what about them for the
most part you know what they do they
vote with incumbent
managers it's easy path and I don't
blame them at somebody from the
Vanguard index funds last week in an
Executive MBA class that I taught it
Stern if you're in Vanguard how the heck
are you going to show up a older meeting
said every company own shares and then
actually throw your weight around first
it's not your money to throw the weight
around with and second that's a lot of
companies most institutional investors
vote with their feet which means if they
don't like a company guess what they do
they sell their shares and move on they
don't stand and fight so if you look at
an annual meeting not only do you
individual investors not show up
institutional investors you know
essentially what with it's very
difficult to get something going it's
incumbent
manag so if you don't like the way a
company is managed and you're saying I'm
going to go do something at the annual
meeting all the more power to
you but you're embarking on a mission
that is going to be really really really
difficult to Wi we'll talk about what
might tilt the scales but most annual
meetings and this gets even
worse outside the US in Japan for a long
time income managers used to hire Yakuza
Yakuza are these
gang members they' show up at annual
meetings and this actually happened
because there was an activist investor
in the US showed up at a Japanese
company and he wanted to question
management every time he stand up to ask
a question group of people in the back
would get up and yell as loud as they
could theyes and you would never get the
question
through in Europe it's a different kind
of problem I remember this company
called tattingers have you heard of it
know it's a French company in very makes
very expensive stuff that most of us can
live without it used to be a
family-owned company but it's now a
publicly traded company and the CEO of
the company is Claudia taton you're
saying that's a coincidence she has the
same last name it is the the family and
this was an annual meeting this activist
investor from the US called Asher
Edelman gets up and he asked a question
which I thought was a very reasonable
question he said I noticed that tat just
the company owns a lot of
chat who lives in these
shat she refused to answer the question
after the meeting she had a press
conference she said no I am Hur that
that such a rude question would be asked
of
me I Now understand why they the
guillotine the French
Revolution this is this is about as
separated from what you should be asking
as a CEO of a publicly traded company
and for the longest time European annual
meetings were exquisitely well-managed
and well behaved Affairs because you
didn't ask those rud questions that's
for the Riff
Raff annual meetings are tough to break
through for lots of different reasons
and you can see why they're say what
about the board of directors what about
the board of
directors I know many of you might have
worked at publicly traded companies I
want you to go back and look at the
annual report for the company you worked
at and look at the board of directors
for your company then ask yourself the
question comes up with these names did
they pull them out of a phone book is
there even such a thing as a phone
book in most companies for a long time
you know who came up with the names
right the CEO
did I remember when John Mack became CEO
of Morgan Stanley the first three
people that he pulled for the board were
members of his country club and I
entirely understood what was going on
let's say you're the CEO of a company
want to put together a board of
directors I let you pick the next you
have two choices you can pick the 12
most informed intelligent people who ask
you tough questions and keep you on your
to that's Choice one the other is you
can pick the 12 most
sloshed people at a bar and put them on
your Port which one's going to make your
life easier you have enough martinis
flowing you'll never get asked a
question that China investment you lost
6 billion not a problem bring me another
Martini Boards of directors are often
composed of people that the CEO picks I
know there's a nominating committee now
but if you're operating under the
delusion that that nominating committee
doesn't check with the CEO before they
put a name on then you're not hanging
out with the people who tend to be
directors at
companies so if you look
at I don't know why my the clickers work
in practice what
happen the pick
directors second you're saying but these
directors must be shareholders in the
company right technically they often are
but you know how they get the shares the
company often gives them the shares they
don't even make them buy them and you
buy 2,000 shares in invate trust me
you're not thinking like a shareholder
you're thinking like a board member
and it's astonishing how many companies
have other company CEOs on their board
I've never understood how somebody has
the time to be the CEO of a company and
sit on the board of another
company the bottom line is it's you'd
love to believe that Boards of directors
act as a check on management but they
don't there a couple of reasons one is I
think you've seen Robert rules of orders
I think this must this guy was some kind
of a pun person who had some
psychological issues you wanted to meet
out punishment it's a way of keeping
order it's a very very so if you want to
run a meeting you want to make sure that
you control the meeting you bring out
Robert's Rules of Order that's out of
order requirement of staying with order
the second is if you're in a room with
11 other people you feel this urg to be
a team
player so if you have a question you
sometimes hold back because said that
might not be a nice thing to ask
I know in the last 30 years we paid lip
service to corporate
governance it started with the scandals
of the late 90s lip service in what
sense you know this this entire law
called sarban Oxley that was written to
make boards more independent key word is
independent and it actually accomplished
that objective and you can't have
Insiders on the board you can't have
your nephew your niece you can have
loopholes to get them there but
generally it pushed Independence
and the Assumption was if you have an
independent board it will be an
effective
board and the two are very different
requirements right independent just
means you don't have this connections
conflicts of interest effective means
you're willing to push back so 30 years
after s it's actually 23 years since SB
Oxley guess what corporate governance
doesn't seem to have changed even though
youve got this immense law that was
passed you're saying
why I think that there is a psycholog
iCal issue you're in a room you're a
director at Goldman Sachs the CEO of
Goldman Sachs gets up and says this is
what we're doing at as Goldman
Sachs psychologically you feel the need
to say that guy is the authority figure
that person is the authority figure he
or she must know more about the company
than I do I'm not going to push back
you you know what if you really want to
make boards more effective maybe we need
to learn from the Catholic church I
let's give let's give it credit it's
been around 2,000 years it's figured out
a way to survive and prosper because the
Catholic church had a problem in the
four in the I think the 14th or the 15th
century too many people were becoming
Saints you follow the process for
becoming a saint the Catholic Church
somebody comes up with the name then a
whole group of people come up with all
these Miracles and they go to Rome and
they present the
evidence and then Rome says yes
no and it turned out that too many
people were becoming
Saints because there was this group
pushing for a saint but there was nobody
who had an incentive on the other side
to mount an argument against St so too
many people going through so the
Catholic Church created a position and I
love the name of the called The Devil's
Advocate the devil's advocate's job was
to push back against the saood people
it's a miracle no no not a miracle the
water would have come out of the ground
anywhere
brought this person back to life no the
person was just sleeping to woke him
up I proposed this a couple of years ago
in a corporate governance session nobody
took it on I said what we need is the
equivalent of a devil's advocate in the
board the CEO you have a counter CEO the
CEO brings out Bankers to say this deal
is a good one the counter CEO has given
the resources to H his bank that deal is
a bad one I know this will bring the
process to a grinding halt but
independent boards are not necessarily
effective
boards so I'm going to show you as the
end of the class the worst board I've
ever seen at a large publicly traded
company in history I'll start the
process there complete the condemnation
next next
session this was the board created at
Disney in 1997 anybody remember who the
CEO of Disney was 1997
a guy called Michael eer guy with an ego
so large that he could be in a big
office by himself and it felt
crowded he was an imperial CEO you know
what an imperial CEO is like Caesar
right make decisions affirmation
follows and this was the body he put
together so let's
start
with Michael Eisen says he's on the
board which is not unusual see is on but
he's also the chair of the board I've
never understood this you chair a board
that's supposed to oversee you and tell
you whe know it sounds like there's a
conflict of interest but that used to be
common in 1997 that was standard across
us companies but let's go through some
of the other names there was Miss RTO
Bowers you saying who the heck is she
it's a principal of an elementary school
in La he saying this is good Disney's a
kid oriented company she's around kids
all day this might have been pure coinci
but she happened to be the head of the
elementary school that Michael eisa's
kids went to complete coci said that to
the South right let's keep going down
there is Father Leo odonovan any
Georgetown this is good to have a
religious influence on this hean board
right again it might be pure coincidence
Michael eisen's son had gone to
Georgetown he sat on the Georgetown
Sport and he made a substantial
contribution to the Georgetown ow set
that aside pure coincidence
again here's my favorite one irin
Russell attorney at law you say what do
you have against lawyers a lot but this
is not the forum for me to discuss that
he was Michael eisner's personal
attorney how the heck do you get away
with this I'm going to put my lawyer on
the board and he's going to be
independent it's nice to have your
lawyer in the room all the time saying
don't answer that question Mike take the
fifth on that one Mike but don't don't
tell me he's going to be an independent
person and to top it all
off Sydney poer great actor right he
actually made the list of top 10
directors in 97 but it was a wrong list
list of directors who missed the most
meetings so guess who's coming to dinner
is guess who's not coming to the meeting
today and he chaired the compensation
committee this is what a rubber stamp
board looks like you know what rubber
stamp board does basically the CEO says
this is what I want to do rubber stamp I
want to acquire a company to rubber
stamp I want to buy ABC rubber
stamp and it's more common than you
realize so here's my first task for you
and this is why I want you to pick a
company early pick a company and for the
moment you might not have picked the
final company pick any company you're
interested in take a look at the board
and ask yourself how effective don't get
distracted by how diverse the board is
how independent the board is all those
are diversions how effective is this
board going to
be because they have a singular task act
as a check and manager so on Monday we
will continue with this discussion
corporate governance but by then I hope
you're in a group and I hope you picked
a company so start that process this
weekend